فجاتني رساله على الجوال
صاحب الهويه رقم
الرجاء سداد مبلغ
عده ملايين ريالات خلال فتره خمس ايام
مع تحيات وزاره العدل
كملوا
اكثر من اربع ملايين
ثاني يوم
تم صدور منع سفر
بعد منع السفر
تجميد الحسابات البنكيه وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
رفعت الجلسه
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح هذه حلقه مختلفه هي قصه غير انها
قصه ممتعه هي دروس مهمه في التجاره لكل
احد يفكر انه يسوي مشروعه ما يفهم في
المجال شيء تسمع خويك في الاستراحه يقول
يبغى يسوي مغسله والعامل بيعطيها عشره
الاف ريال شهريا هذا الرجال خله يسمع هذه
القصه اول او اللي يقول خلنا نروح الصين
ونجيب القطع بريال ونبيعها هنا بعشره ريال
برضو كيف بيبدا خليه يسمع هذه الحلقه ضيفي
اخذ مقلب وضربه على راسه ومن السفر تجمدت
كل حسابات البنكيه لمده سنتين بسبب غلطه
في هذه الحلقه عبد الله ابو الخير تاجر
فتح اكثر من عشر مشاريع كلها كلها الا
ثلاثه القصه فيها جانب ثاني الجانب المظلم
من التطور التقني اللي يخلي الانسان مجرد
رقم في قاعده بيانات طاقه زر وبدون اي احد
يعرف اي شيء وممكن بقرار من النظام ان
تجمد ارصدتك او توقف خدماتك يعني هي جانب
مهم انه الحياه تصير اسرع وهذا في الغالب
لكن في اوقات ممكن تعقد حياه شخص لسنوات
قبل ان نبدا عندنا بودكاست جديد مع العزيز
والصديق الدكتور محمد الحاجي البودكاست
يساعد في فهم نفسك وعقلك وكيف تشكلت
شخصيتك وكيف تتخذ قراراتك بناء على ابحاث
ومعلومات علميه دقيقه بسرد قصصي بديع
بودكاست ادم ابحث عنه او اي تطبيق بودكاست
اخر والرابط موجود في وصف هذه الحلقه اما
الان
لنبدا الحين انا سمعت عندك عشر شركات
شركه وتسع مؤسسات ممكن فيعني عشر مشاريع
مختلفه نعم ايش هي
وحده طيب اول شيء اللي هي اول حاجه العقرب
الان صار اسمها الجديد الوساطه العقاريه
مع الهيئه العامه ممكن
صارت الان شبكه ايجار تسوي العقود عن طريق
الشبكه
الان مثلا تسوي الوساطه العقاريه اللي هي
السعي سابقا
هذه اول هذه اول شيء بديت فيها لا اول انت
تبغى من البدايه ولا بشكل عام بشكل عام
العقارات محطات بنزين
سوينا مع شركه اسمه
هذه دخلت قوه في الدمام
واخذنا في الغربيه والجنوب بس بدانا في
الغربيه جده ومكه وش الفرق لو انك انت
سويت محطتك باسم يعني
فرق كبير
اول لما كنت اشتغل بنفسي كنت انا اجيب
العامل اللي يعبي للناس وانا اطلب الوايت
وانا
ارامكو بس عن طريق متعهدين او مشغلين
انا اذا صار في مثلا فلوس ما هي مضبوطه من
بعض الناس
مزور مزور انا اللي اكل الاتهامات
عندك بعض الاحيان البنزين الاخضر
هو اللي يمشي اكثر من احمر
تكتشف انك الشركه جابت لك احمر بدل اخضر
وصل الوايت عندك في الموقع ايش تسوي فيه
تكفى يا صديق
تكه فوق القهوه عشان ايش نبيع بسرعه عشان
يخلص ما تقدر تعبي فوق هذا لانه
الشركه يبدو لي حساباتها افضل انا كيف
حساباتها فانت بديت اول شيء اصلا بنفسي
بديت محطه يعني اذكر كان
الرفاعي
كنا نسميها باسم ونتبارك اوكي
فكان اذكر الخزانات العمال طبعا اللي
يتحملوا
البنغلاديش والهنود واليمني يتحملوا الجو
الجميل عندنا والزبائن
الزباين البنزين
بعضها يجيك واحد نفسيه
طب ايش فل ولا بريال ولا بعشره وما يبغى
يفتح الشباك حرف فاللي يتحمل هذه النوعيه
هذه الثلاث جنسيات انا اسوي زي كذا
[ضحك]
اومكو ميزتها
اللي هي قبلت تجيبها
تزوير وش يصير تاكل يعني اذكر موقف حصل
طبعا هذا كله كيف يا جماعه
[ضحك]
اذكر مره
طبعا ذيك الايام كان جهاز كذا صغير ليزر
ازرق في جرير ينباع الوحيد يبيعه ريال
تفحص واحده واحده ولازم تكوني على
بروفيشنال ومركز وعندك زي الاضاءه يا
جماعه احنا في اليوم كم سياره تعدي طيب
عندي اكثر من خمس فروع كان فكريه تفحص ايش
ولا ايش والعامل راتبه 1200
حتى هو يقول لي احنا شغل مستعجل يا بابا
كيف احنا نفحص كل 500 طبعا هي التزوير
دايما 500 ما يجيك مثلا عشره ريال ما
الطبع
فاذكر كان في
واحد من الشباب
سلمتهم مبلغ كاش كبير
طبعا الاجهزه الايداع لمن يزيد عن خمسين
الف
يرمي لك القروش كذا قدامك في
الطابور عقب تدور وتحوس والظرف يطيح صرت
خلاص ما اروح اودع في الماكينه ابدا اذا
المبلغ فوق الخمسين اروح للصرافه للموظف
البنغاليه هم المتخصصين في التزوير يرموا
لك كل فتره وفتره ثلاث الاف الفين
وخمسميات بين الايراد
خليني اقول حق الاربعه ايام خمسه ايام
ماكينه الصراف قويه جدا فتلقاها تطلع صوت
فهذاك يحسن الظن في العميل فيقوم بعيد
ويعطيه الصوت يبدا يتحسس الورقه ولا
عندهم نظام
زميلك مو زميلك
باحث الاداريه شغل رسمي
فهذا موظف في الوسام الوسام اللي هو الخاص
فحب يعني يترقى على حسابي
المحضر يعني انا حسيت انه في شيء غريب
يعني تلفون وكذا
فكان مدير
الفرع ما يتقاعد
جاء اخذ الفلوس المزوره
كذا بطريقه سحبت
هذا بيعرض علي تمويل يعني طريقته غريب
قال لي والله في فلوس ما هي مضبوطه ايش
وضعك انت شكلك كذا ما انت في حق سكه
المزورين لا والله انا عندي محطات بنزين
قال لي اسمه
شقها الزباله هو طلع يبعدني عشان
الكاميرات
الان الشخص هذا اللي كان بيطلع على حسابي
الان هو زميلي في البيت يزورني في المكتب
ومسؤول عن الحساب
فكانت هذه شغلة البنزين في مغاسل الملابس
اه الحين هذا يعني ما اتكلم لك بالتسلسل
اتكلم لك الانشطه
لوحدك كانت محطه رفاعي بعدين قلتوا
بتاخذون وكاله اي هذا الوكاله قبل تقريبا
سنتين سنتين
الجيش اللي بيختلف منه الوكاله
يختلف الله يسلمك
يعني منطقي المطعم انهم خلطات حقتهم بجيب
العماله يعني اول حاجه
انا وصل كلامك سليم انا وصل عندي قد
الامانه فوق الثمانين
تقريبا موزعين على خمسه
لما جاء المقابل المالي
هو كان ريال ميه ريال
2500 ريال
4,600 على الشخص غير التامين والجوازات
هذه بس مقابل
من هنا بدات هذه الرسوم الاضافات الحكومه
العمل 2016 فحسينا انه في شيء غلط عندنا
احنا ادخل في التشغيل خلاص انت خليك بس
وجيب ناس متخصصين طب يا اخي ادريس كيف
بيدفع ادريس اول شيء ما يجيب العامل اللي
انا اجيبه والظاهر يجيب بالجمله اتفق معهم
بسعر معين يعني انا مثلا لما اجيبه ب 1500
انا اتحمل السكن
واتحمل لو صار له اي شيء التامين الشركات
تامينهم اسهل
الشيء الثاني موضوع الشركات الكبيره هذه
عندها نظام في
متعهدين من الوايتات
يعني انا كنت كيف اعرف ان الباقي عندي
اخضر والاحمر
كان عندي متر
تقول كان مفصل ثياب نقيس انا والبنغالي
باقي نص اطلب طيب زحمه السير بيجي قبل
بالبركه خلاص يجي قهوته فوق
بارنيز مذاك المغربي قهوه
الشركات لا صار مربوط الخزان مع الطرمبه
البنزين كم باقي في
الخزان فيطلب على اثرها
هذه ريحتنا موضوع الايداع البنوك الصرف
الشركات تريحك
موضوع انت ربحك يجيك نهايه السنه مفرق
شركه تعطيك شيك
مقدم هذا جدا مريح اربح مع الشركه ولا
يمكن لا مع الشركه يعني لوحدي
اذكر مره جالس
الساعه ثلاثه في الليل في واحده من
المواقع
احنا تمام كذا ولا تمام
ولا شكلكم
[ضحك]
الساعه ثلاثه يجوا ناس معاهم طبعا العامل
اللي يتكلم
يقول شاف سلاح
طيب العامل ما يعرف ايش الاجراءات وبيتصل
بصاحب الموقع يعني هو سوبر مان هيجيك مثل
الساعه ثلاثه ويحارب هذولا يا اخي في شيء
اسمه ما عنده هذه الثقافه
فتلقى دائما اللي عندهم الاجرام هذول
يدوروا على المواقع الا تكون في الحاره ما
يروح للمواقع الرئيسيه
ويروح للمواقع اللي يحس انه ما هي برنت
يعني بعد على الدريس انه هذولا بداوا
بالكاميرات او الناس بداوا بالسلام
والاجرام يبداوا خلينا نقول بالافراد احنا
كان يطلق على المحطات الافراد
فكان يعني الضرر يجي علي كبير
في شيء مهم الصيانه
الصيانه للشركات اسهل موظف الصيانه وهو
مداوم في الشركه مع سياره انا اضطر اجيب
واحد يقول لي والله الجدول اليوم فل
انتظرني
مثلا بعد ثلاث ايام طب انا عندي اربع
مكائن لما تتعطل لوحده انت بتاخذ لي سوقي
فكان يعني الشركات افضل من ناحيه
طرمبات البنزين
عندي موقع في الخط السريع بين جده ومكه
فالكداده الله يحفظهم السيارات البيضاء
هذه سكويا ما انساه محمل معتمرين
ويبدو لي انه كانت زحمه ما شاء الله
فما هو منتبه للمسدس فمشي
وجرب معطر
وولعت كان هذاك الموقع كلهم يمنيين
كلنا فرحانين بالكاميرا مركبينها
وحبيبنا شكله ازعاج ولا يلبوا الجماعه
خشوعي مانيات والعمال يطردوا وراهم
بالطرمبه والبنزين
الظاهر جره عشره متر
مع مرور الموقف نزل شاف الطرمبه
الحجاج كل واحد رمى للاحرام حط رجله كان
جنبنا
كنتاكي وكلهم ورا كنتاكي غبار راعي
السكويا سوى حركه حلوه فك المسدس حق هذا
وشغل ونسي الحجاج
[ضحك]
فانا اتصل على
الدوريات وكذا اقول لهم الجماعه في ابيض
قال يا اخي
اجيب لك اياه ويمكن ما راح مكه يمكن مثلا
راح
طب عندك لوحه الكاميرا هذيك الايام اول ما
نزلت ما تلقط اللوحه يعني الجوده ما هي
ضد مجهول
فالحين هذا المحطات هذا رقم كم الحين
اثنين
كان النظام تاخذ
الايجار بثمانيه عشر
ايام الرخص
لا في عقد ايجار ولا في شيء يقيمك المالك
مؤهل بالنسبه له وقع معك بوك من القرطاسيه
يوقع ويمشي
اذا ما ناسبته او شيء يقول لك والله مؤجره
ماجره لكن اللوحه موجوده ثاني يوم
كانت يعني تجربه حلوه تقريبا 14
رسم على المقاس 100000
دخل شهري ثلاثه الاف
صافي
سويت فرعين بعدين حسيت انه في اشياء احسن
من هذا النشاط
طب ما انا قفلته فهل كان
انه هل هو قابل انك تشرف عليه ولا هم
يتعهدون لك بالمبلغ نهايه شهر اول ما بديت
كنت اشرف عليه لما كنت شفت الموضوع مزعج
وين الازعاج صابون محمل كان معي لكزس
شامبو يعني حسيت الوضع شوي ما يخارج
العلاقات
كان اول عام الهندي من كيرلا
يعني كان يقول لي انا واسوي عقد مع
المستشفى
كان جنب المستشفى اسمه العزيزيه او شيء
فالعامل
المنطقه العزيزيه هنود الان نهدد مع الهدف
في العام المغسله بالف وخمسميه والفين
يروح يرتب معاه الممرضات انه اي شيء يخص
المستشفى يعني
فكانوا يعني صراحه الجنسيه هذه
اشهد لهم انهم نظيفين
في البدايه لما كنت انا واياه على قولتهم
اني اجيب كل شيء
كان
متعاون لكن بعد ما صار له
خلينا نقول يعتبر كانه شريك او شيء ما شاء
الله بدا جاب عقود جاب زبائن
بعد كذا انا اشوف النظام
اللي يطلق عليه الحين التستر وكذا يعني
ما حد يمشي هذه المشاريع اذا انت ما وقفت
عليه فانت خليك بعيد طالما ما هو مجالك
الجنسيه
اعطي الخبز خبازه
كان في حي قوي عندنا في جده اسمه الصفا
اتفاق كان على مبلغ شهري مقطوع
فطلعت في بالي فكره انه ليه ما ازود
المبلغ
واقنعهم انه في اضافه جديده
فرحت معارض السيارات واشتريت لهم الدباب
السوزوكي هذا
موديل السنه كان يوم 45 الف
طيب يا اخي الناس تجيب من الحراج لا ما
شاء الله علي انا
على الموقع اقول تفضل هذا المفتاح انهبل
العامل
فرح بعدين رجعت الضربه اللي هي ايش ترى
زادت 3000 عليكم الايجار عشان جبت لكم يا
اخي ما نبغى يا اخي انسان حالهم
فكانوا محترفين في
صد الضربه
فخلوني اسبوع فرحان حتى ما كملت الشهر اخذ
ثلاثه
يا عم انا انسرق الباص
[ضحك]
في المكان في حاره تحت المستوصف
والعجيب انه العامل ما انساه
باب اني اخوف وقلت له ترى بنروح للشرطه
قال انا معاك
يلا
فندخل الضابط الضابط يقول
للعامل كيف
المفتاح وين
قبل المفتاح
خليته على المكان صاحي ناس تحط الحياه
ما شاء الله مع الكلام
ولا ارتبك ولا شيء
طبعا هو اللي مخبيه بعدين تجيك
سجلوا المحضر والعامل ورقمي
طبعا انا بس بفرح باول 3000 اسد 45 الف
خربوا علي
بعد ثلاثه ايام يتصلوا ونروح
اول ما وصلنا الباص العمال يمين يمسكوني
اعملوا لا تمسك عشان المباحث احنا تكلمنا
المباحث عشان البصمات يعني هم يعلموني
قالوا لي اسماء طالما مغسل هذه مشاكل
فشفنا لك زبون
اخراج يعني انت تخرج تجيب لنا باص وهذا
احنا هنخليك تخرج من المشروع باخراج جميل
بالفعل يوم يومين ما لقي الا واحد
ضابط في الجوازات
كاش
كم قيمه المعدات كم هذا خسارتك الديكور
مع صدمه الباص صدمه البصمات والبهدله حقت
الشرطه
فقلت سبحان الله انت جاي تبغى تضحك عليهم
برفع قيمه الايجار الا هم خلوهم تخرج من
المشروع
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
طيب هذه المغسله
طيب في عندنا
الكهرباء هذه اللي فيها الكلام
معدات كهرباء وكذا كان طلعت وقتها اسمها
الموفره الطاقه هذه
ثاني واحد يقول لي
تبغى تقلب
نقلب اللي ميه مئتين على طول
ايش النشاط هذا العجيب
بثلاثه ريال تبيعها 8000
بسم الله
كيف خبرتك قال لي انا
يعني درسها دراسه
فقلت له بسم الله
خبرتك في الكهرباء اول شيء انا اشتري منه
اللمبه واركبها بالبيت واحط مبلغ والى
اخره
هذا الكهرباء هذه اللي قصتها
طيب عندك بعدين
توزيع مياه
زي برين بس
هذا المشروع الثاني تبغى نرجع الكهرباء
بعد الكهرباء مو قصه اليوم
فخلها
فالتوزيع المياه توزيع المياه شيء زي اي
مويه نوفا كان اسمها رند
رند
[موسيقى]
احسن لك ما كان جديد
يعني كانت الفكره انه القاعات الافراح
نزلت موضه انه بدل ما اجيب كواريب يجيب
كاسه
الكاسه
توقف علينا بثلاثه ريال اربعه ريال
ونبيعها بسته ريال
الكرتون يقف علينا باربعه ريال
ونعتمد على كميه السحب من القاعات
والحارس حق القاعه والمشرف ياخذ عموله مع
الشباب فتلقى يقول لعمو هذا تمشي في العرس
فيقولوا هذيك مو اقوى يقولوا لا هذه اقوى
طبعا هو عشان ايش العمر
تدخل هالمجال
عندنا احد الاقارب
يعني سوى يسموا معمل معمل مياه شربه وكذا
فقال لي اذا عندك عمال وكذا ما شاء الله
انا عندي العمال الفائضين وكذا بسم الله
كل المشاريع وقفت
مع المقابل
ما عدا البنزين
والعقار
والنشاط الخيري
احسن النجم المقابل
يعني انا قلت لك وصل عدد العماله حوالي 80
اليوم واحد
حرفيا تدخل عندي في التامينات واحد
شلون
نقل كفاله
يعني ما كنت تحتاجهم بس
انا التشغيل عندي لا خلاص العقار انا
الواحد هذا يعني خلينا نقول اللي يحصل
الايجارات يعني يعتبر
وطبعا انا اتكلم على
السعوديين في اثنين المساله اتكلم على
الاجانب اللي كانوا اول ثمانيه بيجي واحد
المقابل المالي كان يعني
زي اللي يعمل لك
قبل ما تسوي اي مشروع دراسه جدول اول ما
تشيل هم يعني هو انت متخيل المشاريع
التجاريه
ما هو من الشروط انه يكون العمل على
الكفاله
فتلقى العامل اللي كان يشتغل عندي
كفيل اذكر واحد كان يقول لي في رفحه
اليوم ما تقدر تسوي هذا الشيء
اليوم اذا ما هو على كفالتك ويحمل الكرت
الصحي اذا كان مجالك مثلا غذائي وكده ما
تقدر تشتغل
فهذا سبب الاختفاء الثمانيه طبعا اللي نقل
كفاله الا رجع لبلده يعني طيب الحين عندك
المويه وش كمان طيب في عندنا نشاط رياضي
قبل العمليه
ايش كنت تسوي يا مخرج احنا
عشان بدينا
الفكره الرياضي كانت تقريبا
طلعت عندنا منطقه اسمها
منطقه هذه كانت
يعني تعتبر بعيده فسار اي واحد عنده ارض
كشافات
حارس لوحه للايجار ساعه بمئتين
زي زي الان ضربه ترند بادل كانت الملاعب
الكوره فحبينا ندخل في هذا المشروع
وسبحان الله يعني
برضو هذه من الاشياء تنصح فيها الشباب انه
التخصص حلو يعني ركز في نشاط معين ما ينفع
مركب
مياه هذا نشاط مركب رياضه محطات عقارات
مغسله ملابس نشاط خيري يعني انت في
النهايه يعني تخيل انت كل نشاط انا لي وجه
يعني
النشاط الخيري له طابع معين الفريق اللي
معاك تستاهل معين صحيح البنزين نفس الشيء
يعني الى
فهذه كانت تسوي لي اشكاليه يعني تخيل انت
عندك اجتماع
مع دعاء في الاشياء الخيريه بعدها اجتماع
مع كرجين
فتقلب الكلام والاسلوب فالسبحه تخرج مع
العقاري
يعني فكانت شويه الموضوع يعني كان بالنسبه
لي يعني احس نفسي كاني
في مسرحيه شخصيتك هنا غير شخصيتك هنا غير
شخصيتك فوق العمال مع العمال لازم تكون
صارم ما تبتسم
في نشاط العقارات بتقابل الرجال الاعمال
فكان هذا الموضوع كان مزعج
بس مواليد
يعني طيب في نشاط برضو كان يعني في له
ضربات قاسمه
المقاولات
يعني سوق المقاولات
حاولنا نجمع انه
عقار تطوير عقاري اذا المقابله
هل عندك تطوير عقاري كمان اللي هو
المقاولات طيب هل انت اذا انت عقاري هل
لازم تكون مقاول
يعني سبحان الله كل واحد له تخصصه ورزقه
فدخلنا المقاولات يعني صارت فيها كوارث
وبرضو نشاط اخلق
هذا رقم كم الان سبعه سبعه طيب الثامن
في عندك الخيري الخيري تكلم عنه
كانت ايام سيول جده والاشياء اللي ضربت
جدا وكذا
فكانت فكره اللي هو
مناطق تجمع
كان يحددها الدفاع المدني تكون هذه
المناطق هي المناطق الانقاذ او
نقطه التواصل
فكانت هذه المنطقه تجتمع فيها جميع
الجمعيات والاوقاف وكذا فكان زمزم اشياء
صحيه اسعافيه تطور فرق الى اخره
الدفعه الرباعي السيارات
فكانت الفكره انه احنا نتخصص في توزيع
السلات الغذائيه وكذا
فلما يكون النشاط ما هو مرتب
يتواجهك عقب يعني زي المانحين لما ما يكون
عندك مثلا سجل او ترخيص
يقول لك لا اروح
لمنصات رسميه وكذا افضل
فجلس مع احد المحامين الزملا الان الاوقاف
اللي سهلت الامور
وعندك وزاره الموارد وزاره العمل
الاجتماعي سهلت عليك انك تسوي جمعيه وهذه
شروطه وهذه شروط الاوقاف فوجدت ان الاوقاف
اسهل مناسبه الجمعيه لازم يكون في عدد
معين صحيح
اما الاوقاف انت ناظر الوقف سواء الارض او
المبلغ او الاسهم
الرياض اسهل في الاوقاف من جده
تختلف والعجيب انه في جده
القاضي يسالني يقول لي وين الارض اللي
بتوقفها او وين الاسهم
فاحنا فقلت له الارض
بنجمع قروشها قال انت جاي توقف ارض وانت
ما انت جاهز قلت له انا عندي مبلغ جاهز
فقال لي احنا ما نوقف مبلغ ولا نوقف الا
اسهم او ارض
تفاجات انه في الرياض يوقف المبلغ بشهاده
رصيد بنكي او اثبات كشف حساب
فالرياض دائما هي
العاصمه
فاستخرجنا امورنا ورتبنا امورنا بحيث انه
يكون
مشروع رسمي الحمد لله
يعني فتره الكورونا كان النشاط افضل وحتى
المانحي لما يشوف في اشياء رسميه اللي زي
حساب مثلا رسمي افضل من تحويل الشخص منطقي
طيب دحين
نرجع للكهرباء نعم
طيب في 2012
الفكره كانت انه
منتج سريع
وبالعاميه اللي هو يقلب المبلغ يعني بمكسب
وكانت الجمارك ذيك الايام
دخول البضاعه
يعني مثلا يجيك شخص يقول لك
المنتج هذا مكسبه 100% او 200% مو 5%
وعشره في الميه فانت تتفاجئ انه
هل هذه المعلومه صحيحه لا صحيحه وتعال الى
الصين
هي صحيحه
ولكن صحيحه فقط
بالتنظير والكلام لكن في الواقع لا غير
صحيح ما هي بمئه في المئه قلب كثير
كانت الفكره انه
زياره لكوانزو في الصين
والموظف او المشرف على المشروع
له نسبه معينه
من الربح وراتب شهري
والمندوبين اللي يوزعوا على المحلات
الجمله
نحاول نجيبهم من
السوق يعني ما نجيب واحد غير مدرب لازم
نجيب واحد يكون عنده زبائن فعنده له منطقه
في الغربيه اسمها الجنوبيه هذه المنطقه هي
جنوب جده فسمي الجنوبيه سوق خاص وجمله
الكهرباء واللمبات
فالفكره انه انت تجيب المنتج من كوانزو
الصين الى الميناء
المخرج
الجمارك يدخلوا الى المستودع
ويبدا المندوبين بتوزيع المحلات
انت كتاجر حطيت مبلغ
وبحساباتك ودراستك انه مئه الف ان شاء
الله ترجع لك 200 الف
تطلع الارباح
الرواتب وتطلب الكاونتر الجديد قبل ما
ينتهي الكاونتر الاول بحيث انه تكون
احنا طبعا مو محل احنا مكتب جمله
فالفكره انه انا بنفسي اروح اتاكد من
المصنع بحيث انه
انسان لما يروح يشوف البضاعه في المصنع
ويتكلم مع صاحب المصنع
ويسمع
حسيتها افضل خصوصا يعني الفكره من الدخول
في الشغله هذه تقريبا المبلغ نصف مليون
كانت الفكره انه ندخل بمبلغ نصف لكن على
اجزاء نجرب الكاونتر الاول الثاني
رحنا الصين
كان في مترجم
المترجم كان ما هو رسمي يعني كان صديق
فمرات يرد ومرات مقفل جواله ونبلش مع
الصينيه
وعندهم تعصب اذا ما كنت في مكان رسمي مثلا
فندق عالمي خمس نجوم ما يتكلم انجليزي
فتضطر بالاشارات
الاكل نتعب فيه يعني
ندور ما في المطعم واحد عربي
جالسين هناك
واحنا داخلين المطعم
الصينيين قريب منهم منطقه الطاجكستان
وافغانستان يعني
نصحى تسميه الجنسيه انها من هذه
فكانوا
باسطين ويبيعوا
طبعا انا جاي اكل فول ايش علاقه القران
فيقول لي اتفضل معك ابو بكر يعني على اساس
اني تعال اشتري منه
الثاني يقول لي معاك عمر بن الخطاب جميع
المبشرين بالجنه ما شاء الله
عند البسطه المطعم يعني من باب انه انت يا
عربي يا تاجر او يا خليجي ترى احنا معاك
في كل مكان
هذا عند المطعم عند الفندق اشياء ثانيه ما
نقدر نقولها في الحركه
في الوضع كان غريب المترجم يعني اقول له
لما ادق عليك رد يكون في شيء
اذكركم انا شعري طويل
اسود طويل جو بارد
ويبدو لي انه ما هم متعودين على اللحيه
فطربوش
فكان
الشرطه الصينيه هناك ما تدور الا مجموعات
فدائما اتعرض
تفتيش لانه شيء غريب هذا كان من فين جف
حتى كانوا يقولوا عرب وعربوا
فكان يقول لي
الجواز
احنا الجوازات نخليها في خزنه الاوتيل
فسبحان الله ربي الهمني انه الحمد لله
نزلنا في فندق خمسه نجوم فكانت الخدمه
رائعه المترجم في هذا الوقت والصينيين
يتكلموا واحنا فاهمين ولا شيء انا والاخ
كان موقف مضحك يعني وانا طالع يضحك فيه
وهذولا دائره عشان لا
نفك
ولقيت الكرت
الغرفه
فقلت له كلمهم
اتصل عليهم
بالجوال
فقال لهم يعني هذول الاشخاص الغريبين
الموجودين عندكم وكذا فقالوا نعم موجودين
الحمد لله كانت هذه دائما يعني
لانه احنا ما نزلنا في عاصمه نزلنا في
منطقه يعني تعتبر
منطقه مصانع وكذا كلهم يعني
يعرفوا الاشكال اللي احنا اشكالنا غريبه
كانت
[موسيقى]
انتو شريكك يعني انا اعتبره مشرف المشروع
زرنا المصنع الاول المصنع الثاني طبعا
المنتج تقريبا
كبر هذا الكوب
او الفنجان زي ما تحبوا تسموه في برنامجكم
فتكلفه ثلاثه ريال والفكره البيع بسته
سبعه ثمانيه ريال
بيع سريع جمله بسته ريال
هذا الهدف وهذا الدراسه تبعنا
فوجدنا مصنع
كان كم حتطلب
طريقتهم هم في الشغل في الكوانزو
لما تجي الطلبيه يحضر الموظفين من القريه
من اهل القريه اللي موجودين
كخدمه مجتمع انه يشغله كذا ما في طلبيه
يسرحهم على العمل او ما يحسب عليهم الاجر
فقلت له الطلبيه ممكن نبدا ب 200 او 100
كتجربه
فلم فهمتوا من المترجم انه يقول انه هذولا
يعني
عندنا طلبات بخمسه مليون
فهذا الكلام خلاني يعني
لفت انتباهي انه معقول في شخص يطلب لمبات
بخمسه مليون يعني هذه الكميه كم باخره وكم
كاونتر
فقلت انا معناته ان شاء الله المشروع هذا
زي ما قال المشرف حيكون في عده قلبات
وهي صحيح فيها قلبات ولكن قلبات من نوع
اخر
تفاجات انه
المترجم يقول انه هو ما يستقبل هذه
الطلبيه روح المصنع ثاني
ما عنده تجار
يعني يساعدوا بعض فهذاك المصنع هو يعطيكم
السعر والكميه الكميه لانها قليله نعم
فاذكر رحت للمصنع الثاني المصنع الثاني
حتى مغلق في الخط الانتاج وكذا
فلما جينا بداوا يفتح اللمبات يعني واضح
انه في يعني الموقع مهجور او شبه مهجور
فدائما انت كتاجر يعني تبغى تجيب المنتج
يعني احنا كان ودنا ناخذه بريال عشان
نبيعه بسته ريال
فاتفقنا على ثلاثه ريال
وبدات الرحله طيب مين المخرج اللي يجيبه
فقال لازم تشوفوا لكم واحد موجود عربي
عنده مكتب في الصين
تعرفنا على شخص واتفقنا معاه على السعر
واغلب هذه التجارات بالاجل
يعني المصنع ياخذ الطلبيه بدون ما تدفع اي
مبلغ
ثقته في
صاحب المكتب اللي في الصين
بعد ما توصل
عند الجمارك السعوديه يبدا يتصل بك المصنع
حول المبلغ لان من قبل ما تستلم طيب هذا
النشاط او هذا الدفعه الاولى
وين المستودع اسال الرجال قال لي بسيط
كنت اذكر الكلمه هذه بسيطه عنده في كل
مشكله تواجهني يقول لي بسيط
طيب
الاف اللمبات جايه بحطه في بيتي ولا في
مكتبي وين المستودع قال لي بسيط الان ندور
وجنوب جده الان اغلب الاماكن اللي هي
المستودعات
الان كلها اصبحت في منطقه العشوائيه وحدت
حصلنا عماره
صاحب
خرج السيارات وخلاها مستودع بسيط بمبلغ
وسعر رمزي فوق انا معه
اول كاونتر
وصل للمستودع
ما في اي مندوب
كنا نجيب العماله من الشارع
في التحميل في التنزيل في الرس
في اخطاء حصلت
الجرد مهم جدا في هذه الانشطه البرامج
المخزون المحاسب
حقيقه هو حلو للتاجر انه يوفر ولكن مو في
كل شيء التوفير يكون ناجح
المفروض انت من قبل ما تطلب البضاعه
المحاسبه جاهز
المندوبين ماخذين دورات وكورسات
البضاعه وصلت
المندوب جالسين نختار من الافضل منهم
تقريبا وصل الى سبعه
المحاسب اذكر كان
بنجيب جنسيات ولكن كان جدا كوميدي
مختلف مع المشرف فكنا نتخذ قرار فكانت
تصير عندي زي الحرب في المكتب
المندوبين من جنسيه المشرف والمحاسب من
جنسيه اخرى فكل واحد له راي
فمثلا كيف طريقه العاجل والتحصيل المحاسب
والمشرف لو رايي
فكنت انا اسدد واقارب
وصلت البضاعه
بقول للمشرفه الان جانا واحد يشتري
وين الفواتير
وين المستندات وين الاختام وين المطبوعات
بسيط الان نشوف مطبعه
مرتب معاه
فكان يعني طالما هو روحه في المشروع وقلبه
في المشروع فكان هو اللي يروح للمطبعه
واسوي له الخطاب فكنت اسوي الخطاب
بمطبوعات مثلا اخرى مطبوعات العقار او
مطبوعات انه هذا مندوبنا ومشرفنا فالامانه
من
طلبيه الختم
بعدها بداوا يجون المندوبين الاول الثاني
الثالث حتى وصلوا الى سبعه
الفكره انه
المشرف تكلم المندوبين
المطلوب مسح المستودع ما نبغى تكون عندنا
بضاعه عشان نطلب بسرعه ونقلب القلب هذا
نتكلم عليها
كانت البضاعه الثانيه والثالثه توصل وما
قدرنا نجمع قيمتها فكنت اضطر عشان المشروع
يستمر اضخ مبلغ من مشروع اخر وهذا ايضا
خطا
المفترض ما تطلب الثاني حتى يكون الاول
صفيت ارباحك وتطلب بقيمه
الكاونتر الاول
لكن المشروع جديد والبدايات
والربح مغري والربح مغلي والكلمه المتعارف
عليها القلب القريبه ان شاء الله
فكانت
يعني سفرات الصين كانت يعني انك تروح
للمصنع ومعك المترجم برضو انت كرجل اعمال
رجل اعمال يحب السفر فتلقى دائما يعني
يعشق كلمه والله عندي رحله راح اشوف
المصنع فهذي كانت احنا كشباب يعني
بالنسبه لنا يعني شيء جميل كل فتره وفتره
تروح تشوف مصنعك
تفاجانا انه فكره المشرف انه الاجل
وما في مشكله نوقع مع المحلات الجمله
وننزل البضاعه توصل الى 25 الى 30 الف
ريال
كانت الفكره كل خميس دفعه
فكانوا سبعه المندوبين يدوروا في جده كامل
من الجنوب للشمال من الشرق للغرب تحصيل
يوم الخميس وباقي الايام
تنزيل البضاعه الاليه اللي كانت تسير في
تنزيل البضاعه برضو غلط
انا لما انزل لواحد بالاجل يفضل يكون في
ضمان
يعني من الضمانات شيك مثلا قيمه البضاعه
وهذا الشيك يكون بطريقه مثلا مع قانوني او
مكتب محامي
يحفظ حقوق الطرفين في حال مثلا قدرته على
ارجاع المبلغ او سدادت تعادل بضاعه
الخلل اللي صار هنا انه كان التنزيل
عشوائي
لمبتنا افضل من لمبتكم لا لمبتكم ارخص من
لمبتنا طب خذ لمبتنا وجربها يلا نزلوا
بضاعه ب 25 الف
ابو فيصل ابشرك المستودع اتمسح
طب وين المبلغ كل خميس ان شاء الله بيجيك
فعلا كل خميس يجيني ولكن ما يغطي قيمه
يوصل الى 200 الف التحصيل يوصل في الاسبوع
12000 فرق كبير وانت عندك المصنع اذا وصل
وقرب من الميناء يعطيك اتصال حول لو سمحت
على حساباتنا
يعني لاحظت انه في
اخطاء يعني مو كل شخص متميز في المهنه قد
يكون ناجح في تجاره المهنه قد يكون هناك
ناجح في تركيب
اللمبه او في صيانتها لكن مو شرط يدير
المشروع فبدت الاخطاء
تقريبا وصلنا الى خمسه طلبيات كبيره
حصل وقتها 2015
او 16 المقابل المالي لو 6400 او 4600
فبدات اصحاب المحلات
والانشطه الان من 2012 الى 2016 15
هل بدات تقلب ولا لسه فانا اللي كنت انقلب
فقط
يعني كنت اخذ من ارباح مشاريع اخرى واحطها
في المشروع
وكان هذا جدا مزعج ولكن التاجر دائما يقول
لك اذا حطيت لوحتي هذي كلمه دائما اسمعها
من كبار التجار اذا حطيت لوحه ما انسحب من
السوق يعني حتى لو طلع الايجار فقط
وهذا يعني انا اشوفه غلط
اي مشروع ما يكسب السنه الاولى السنه
الثانيه تصحيح محاوله ما تستمر خمس سنوات
فالخطا اني انا مستمر
الهزه اللي صارت في المقابل المالي
الكبيره اغلب اصحاب المحلات يبدو لي
الجمله
كانت تستر
فكان المندوب من الاشياء الطريفه يوصل
للمحل كان مثلا
اللمبه الخضراء نفترض كذا اسمه نتفاجئ فول
السعاده
فالمندوب يكلمني يقول لي كان هنا المحل
اللمبه والله متاكد اني سلمتوا هذه
الفاتوره وهذا رقم الجوال يا ابو فيصل صار
فول طبعا
الفتره التصحيحيه خلت اصحاب المحلات
المتسترين مختلفين مع كفلهم فيقفل جواله
ويهرب صاحب العقار يلقى العقار موجود
ياجره اي نشاط اخر
في المندوب الاول يصيح المندوب الثاني
يصيح المندوب الثالث يعني صار الوضع
يعني قلبه شديده جدا
تعثر وليس قلبه فكلمته المشرف قلت له يا
اخونا الفاضل احنا عندنا دروب قوي
الكونترات الان حجايه من الصين وما في
مبلغ جاهز حنضطر نستخدم بيع ارض
من مشروع ثاني عشان نغطي المشروع هذا ما
ينفع
يعني شوف حد قال لا الان انا بتواصل مع
المندوبين السبعه والى اخره والسيارات
تنزل وانا عارف انه صعب التصحيح لانه انت
القرارات اللي اتخذتها صعب في التوزيع
الاتي لازم يكون في اليه واضحه
الجميع استلم راتبه
ومخالصه لكل واحد
وتم اغلاق النشاط في 2015 كم كانت خسارتك
الف ريال الخساره الله يعوضنا ان شاء الله
بعض المندوبين
طلب نقل الكفاله انا دائما اللي بينقل
كفاله ينقل واللي يبغى يسافر نهائي يسافر
يعني انت بالخيار بس انت اللي تقرر مش انا
هذا المندوبين يعني ما يعرف يتخذ قرار
يعني اذكر واحد يقول لي انت لا تقرر لي
قلت له انا اقرر مصيري بس ما اكرر مصيرك
انت تبغى تحب تجلس في البلد هذي قال لي
وين اروح اشتغل قلت له هذا قرارك فكانت
اشياء يعني سبحان الله تعامل الناس عقليات
وكذا
الشاهد انه جميع المندوبين نقلوا كفاله
الى انشطه اخرى ما هو كهرباء
المشرف
الرئيسي في المشروع
طلب نقل كفاله
تقريبا في نفس النشاط خاص في الكهرباء
والتكييف والى اخره الرجال صامل في
القلبات والله يوفقه ويرزقه لكن انا
بالنسبه لي
يعني
من يوم ما جاني طلب الموافقه في وزاره
العمل عملت موافقه
والله يستر على فلوسي والله يعوضني والله
يرزقه
انتهت القصه هذه ويعني خلينا نقول تجربه
مره تحكيها لاولادك اخوانك زملائك اي واحد
بيفتح مشروع في الكهرباء كنت يعني اعطيه
بعض
التنبيهات او النصائح والاخره السجل شطب
الحساب البنكي اغلق
العماله جميعها نقلت يعني خلينا نقول
مخالصه المخالصه بالكامل
القصه بالنسبه لي انتهت ولكن هي بدات قبل
سنتين
اذكر هذا التاريخ جيد كان وقتها
مباراه كره قدم دوري محلي
جالس في البيت اتفرج وانا من النوع اللي
اذا كان في يعني شيء ساخن كذا دوري احب
اكون يعني لوحدي في البيت والاولاد الا في
نادي ولا في نشاط اكاديمي
رساله على الجوال
صاحب الهويه رقم
وفي اخر رقمين من هويتي
الرجاء سداد مبلغ
عده ملايين ريالات خلال فتره خمس ايام
مع تحيات وزاره العدل
كملوا
اكثر من اربع ملايين
يعني العلي شكيت في الرقم طبعا المباراه
انا نسيت اشي المباراه
فرجعت للرساله مره ثانيه اشوف يمكن يكون
زودوا اصفار او شيء احنا متعودين
بالكهرباء المويه موبايلي زين الى اخره
فواتير الف وخمسميه الى
ارسلت هذه الرساله لاحد المحامين اللي
معانا في الفريق وقلت له هذه الرسائل هذه
اسمها رساله تنفيذيه
طب تخص ايش
يعني الواحد يعرف تخص اي مبلغ قال لي
والله انا ما اعرف انت صاحب الشام ما تعرف
قلت له والله انا ما اعرف
في عداء بينك وبين قلت له والله اذا في
اداء فانا دائما انا اللي اخسر صاحب العمل
هو اللي يتحمل يعني انت ما تحمل العامل
الخساره انت اللي تخرج راس المال الجبان
فاذا دخل راس الماء المفسر انت الخسرت
فمين الشخص هذا المعتد
فقال لي طيب حول لي الرسائل لو سمحت انا
اشوف
واجيك الان
قلت له انا اجيك
جهز اللابتوب عشان ندخل على ناجز
في الحقيقه اللي اسمع من الشباب والتجار
والرواد الاعمال انه فتره الكورونا وبعدها
موضوع
القضايا والمحاكم زادت بنسبه كبيره بس ما
تحضرنا النسبه
خلافات بنت تجار خلافات بين صاحب عقار
ومستاجرين كم نسبه الخصم هذه اشياء يعني
النظام خلاها بالتراضي بين الطرفين اول
محاكم هنا تفصل
بس انا لا عندي عقد شبكه ايجار مع شخص
ولاني سويت شيك من غير رصيد ايش هذا الشيء
القوي التنفيذي
دخلنا على ناجز
ما فيش
ما جزء اللي هي البوابه اللي فيها البوابه
الالكترونيه لوزاره العدل حديثه وقويه
ولكن
فيها اكثر من في القضاء وفي التنفيذ
فالموضوع اللي يخص الرساله والقصه تنفيذ
فامكان ما يظهر عندي جلسات وقضاء فكانوا
غير الصدر الحكم صدرت فاتوره يتسمى فاتوره
تنفيذيه
فالمحامي طالع فيا وانا طالع فيه طيب هذا
ايش وضعها
قال لي
في اي خلافات قلت له لا يوجد اي خلاف
وسلقت خلافات يعني ظنوا انه هذا يكون في
قضيه وحكم فيها من محكم مثلا خارج جده
واضحا مثلا يكون القضاء في منطقه اخرى
فيتاخر نزول الصك او الدعوه او الاخره
فكان هذا التفكير
استغربت
وما اعطيت اهتمام للرساله
وتوقعت انه بالخطا
بس لما اشوف اخر رقم الهويه
اقول لا ما هو الخط
ثاني يوم
او ثالث يوم تم صدور منع سفر
كانت الرساله تجيني من اللي هو الخاص
بالرسائل الرسميه ابشروا
اتصلت على زميله المحامي وش الرساله تقول
انه تماما اكمل السفر عزيزي صاحب الهويه
او صاحب الهويه رقم كذا اخر رقمين تم صدور
منع صفر
فاتصلت على المحامي
وقلت له استاذي الفاضل
نبى حل درجات الرساله الاول جانا كم مليون
الان جاني من السفر وبعدين
قال لي والله انا مستغرب ما جاك اي اتصال
قلت ما جاني اي اتصال اي رقم يجيني غريب
عجيب ارد ابعرف مين صاحب المشكله
فجلس تقريبا اسبوع على هذا الحال
النظام طبعا مع التجربه والخبره في الحياه
عرفنا فكره الرسائل كالتالي الفكره الاولى
سداد الفاتوره
عدم السداد بعد خمسه ايام منع السفر بعد
منع السفر
تجميد الحسابات البنكيه
بعد تجميد الحسابات البنكيه تبدا بالقضاء
والجلسات والاخره
الى الان مره تقريبا اسبوع الى اسبوعين
وما نعرف مين الخصم او مين الطرف الثاني
تم منع السفر اول شيء فاتوره مليونيه
او عده ملايين
منع السفر تجويد الحسابات البنكيه ام فيصل
عرفتها ام فيصل عرفت من اول يوم رساله قلت
لها بالغلط في كم مليون صدر علي فاتوره
الله يختار الخير السفر علينا ولا عليك
[ضحك]
فسالت المحامي قلت له هل السفر اذا صاحب
المشكله على صاحب الهويه وعلى اذكر اول
كان الجميع
فقال لي لا على صاحب الرقم اللي هو الحاسب
فكانت الصدمه اخف يعني
تقريبا في الاسبوع الثاني وصلنا اتصال من
جوال
والحمد لله البرامج
الكاشف والنمبر بوك يعني صارت تريح الواحد
طبعا بعض الناس يعني يقول يا اخي ليش رائد
الاعمال او التاجر او اللي يدخل في مجال
البزنس ما يرد على الارقام الغريبه
بعض الاحيان الانسان
ما يقدر يحل كل المشاكل بنفسه فمثلا انا
جايب محامي
بعرف من هو الطرف الاخر
فقال لي معاك المحامي فلان
وقلت له اعتذر عن الرد
حيتواصل معاك المحامي فلان
دائما يعني تعلمنا انه
شيء ما تعرف
ايش عواقبه خلي المختص يتفاهم مع الشخص
الثاني المختص
وطالما هو اتكلم بالصيغه رسميه فانا ارد
عليه برسمي
واعطيت المحامي رقم الطرف الاخر
ورتبوا موعد زياره
كان اللقاء جدا غريب
بين المحامين
اعطوا المشرف حقه
والمحامي يقول من هو المشرف
وايش الموضوع لا الموضوع تشوفوه بعدين في
المحكمه
طيب يا جماعه الخير احنا ما هو لغز
من هو الطرف الاول ومن هو الطرف الثاني
وايش هي القضيه عشان نقدر نوصل لحل ودي
فكانوا المحامي الثاني متعنت
تبغى تحلوها الان ولا بتحلوها في المحكمه
فما يبغى يكشف عن هويه ما يبغى يكشف عن
هويه الخصم وفي نفس الوقت ما يبي يطلع ايش
هو المستند هذا اللي يطلبه
القضاء اذا صدر عليك منع سفر او الى اخره
او اي عقوبه يعني اغلب المتعارف عليه في
الدعاوى يكون في عده جلسات الحمد لله
القضاء عندنا عادل ونزيه ما يحكم من اول
جلسه فبعض الجلسات توصل الى عشره بعدها
يصدر الحكم وبرضو لك حق الاستئناف
العجيب انه هنا انت لاجلس جلسه ولا شفت
القاضي ولا تعرف من هو الخصم
يعني
العقوبات صدرت فورا بالرساله اللي جاتني
وقت مشاهده المباراه الكوره الله لا
يعيدها
هو كان اذكر عبد اللطيف جميل اليوم يعني
تغيرت الامور
اللي حصل انه
الشخص المحامي اصر على عدم كشفه الطرف
الثاني
وفي نفس الوقت انا
كطرف اول
ما عندي استعداد ادفع الريال وانا ما اعرف
هي فاتوره تخص ايش
الظاهر فقط في الرساله
ارقام فاتوره طويله جدا تقريبا من عشره
ارقام او 11 رقم كانه رقم حساب بنكي
سدد هذا المبلغ المليون لديك خمسه ايام
رساله جدا عجيبه
يعني انت تتعامل مع كمبيوتر
وما في شخص تقدر مثلا تتفاهم معاه لا قاضي
لا كاتب لا جلسه لا تحديد موعد فكان جدا
الوضع صعب
في ضربات كثيره تلقيتها في القصص
مع السجلات والمؤسسات بس كانت اغلبها تنحل
خلال 24 ساعه
يعني تخرج راضيه هذا انا ما اعرف خصمي مين
كانت يعني شويه تجربه جديده علي
انا مساهم في عده شركات
فبجلس مع الشركاء بشرح لهم الوضع
فقالوا هذه الايقافات
تصدر على ثلاث اشياء
طبعا الشرك اللي عندي اعمارهم قريب من
الستين فمروا بتجارب الرسائل هذه اكيد
فقال لي الايقافات هذه اللي يسموها
التنفيذيه اغلبها ما تتعدى عن ثلاثه اشياء
اما عقد شبكه ايجار تنفيذي
ما سددته قلت الحمد لله انا في ملك وفي
خير ما في اي عقد ايجار
قال لي يمكن المكاتب اللي انت مستعجل قلت
له المكاتب في عقاراتنا يعني ما في اي طرف
ايجار انا موجود فيك في شبكه ايجار
فاستبعدنا موضوع شبكه ايجار قال لي الثاني
هل حررت هيك من غير رصيد قلت له ما قد
تحركت من غير قال لي الثالثه واظن هي
الثالثه وبالفعل طلعت هي الثالثه قال لي
هل حررت سند الامر
قلت له معلش ايش هو السند الامر ما
استخدمته اصلا اسمع فيه ولكن ما استخدمته
فيه تجاره نهائيه فبدا يشرح لي سند الامر
هو ورقه تجاريه تلتزم فيها للطرف الثاني
بمبلغ الفلاني في التاريخ الفلاني وتختم
وتوقع ويفضل يكون في شهود قلت له ابدا
انا ما قد سويت سند الامر في حياتي ابدا
قال يبدو لي السند الامر اللي هو رقم
ثلاثه هو المشكله اللي انت واقع فيها
المحامي اللي عندك
الزميل
هل مر بهذا التجربه فاتصلت المعامله المره
قال لي لا
فاشاروا علي الشركاء انه نستعين بمحامي
متخصص في هذه الامور
واشار على شخص
في الرياض وانا طبعا موقعي في جده
الان المحامين صار عندهم موقع في فرع في
الرياض فرع في جده فالحمد لله الفرع كان
في نفس الحي اللي موجود في مكتب فكان
يعتبر من الجيران حتى كنت تمزح معاه اقول
له هلا بالجار فكان يقول لي نبغى بيعات
عقار ما نبغى مشاكل وسندات
كان يعني
يلطف علي وقال لي يبغى لك تصبر موضوعك
مطول
تجربه جديده
فكنت اساله دائما طبعا المحامين في النهار
جلسات وقضاء بعد المغرب يبدا على قولتهم
مع العملاء الدردشه
فكنت انا بعد المغرب مجهز القهوه واروح
جسمها يعني انا اروح
استمع للقصه تخصني وانا ما ادري عنها شيء
هذا كان عجيب
فكان يقول لي هل انت تركت في واحده من
انشطتك مطبوعات
هل تركت اختام
فكان جوابي
الاغلب لا
تذكرت مشروع الكهرباء
كانت الخساره كبيره وكانت التصفيه سريعه
فكانت ترتيب المخالصات والخروج ما هو مرتب
فقلت نعم وموجود مع شخص
يبدو لي انه هو صاحب الموضوع
فقال لي حاول تتذكر اشتركت عنده
الايميلات انا احب اتعامل بالايميل لانه
اثبته عندي ورسمي كذا قال انا ما اتكلم
على الايميل
الايميل يعني ما يخترق الايميل الا شخص
محترف وهذا نادر
انت في النهايه منشاه ويعني ما هي منشاه
كبيره شخص يعني يخترق وكذا انا اتكلم على
المطبوعات
والاختم
فكان جوابي بعدين يعني تذكر لانه السند في
تصفيه المنشاه 2015 في فتره طويله
تذكرت ان المشرف كان معاه ابوه كامل
من المطبوعات الرسميه اللي هو جابها من
المطبعه وختم رئيسي نسميه ختم الثاني عند
الطوارئ عند السفر يستخدموا عشان لا تتعطل
الفواتير
فقال لي الله يحفظك زور عليك سند
وترى هذه القصص يعني بدات تنتشر
وعندنا قصه شبيهه
يعني مبلغ فوق السبعه وعشرين مليون سند
امر
والعجيب انه القصه الثانيه ايضا نفس الشيء
مشرف يعني المفروض اللي يكون هو سندك
هو اللي زور يعني خلينا نقول القصتين في
نفس المكتب شبيهه
والاختراق يكون من الداخل المهم من الخارج
طيب
سعاده المحامي اشيل علينا ايش نسوي الان
فقال اول شيء لازم اسمع منك القصه كامله
من بدايه الى النهايه فشرحت له القصه
فقال لما عملت مخالصه المشروع ونقلوا هل
وقعت الجميع على
استلام الرواتب فانا كان جوابي انا احول
على حساباتهم البنكيه والحمد لله
الاشياء هذه سهلتنا بموضوع جدول الرواتب
جدول المعاشات وكان اول ما في زي الحين
مدد والاجور كانت الامور يعني بعض المنشات
تسلم نقدي كان مسموح يعني انا كنت سابق
الناس بدل ما اسلم كنت احول على الحساب
واي ملاحظه نرجع للكشف الحساب موضح فيه
استلام الراتب قال لي طب هل سويت
استلام
الختام والمطبوعات قلت له لا
قال لي طيب هذا خطا
قلت له يعني حتى لو اخطا صاحب المنشاه
في نظام قضاء يحكم
قال لي رفع المستندات مستندات عفوا يكون
عبر الكمبيوتر في ناجز
يعني تخيل الموضوع انه زي الباركود اذا
قرا ونجح الباركود في قراءه السند فيقبل
بدون قاضي
وتتنفذ العقوبه عليك بدون قاضي
كما هو مدون في السند
فكنت اتكلم عن محامي يقولوا يعني لو هو
زود المبلغ الى 100 مليون هل يعقل قال لي
الى مليار
طالما الاركان موجوده
المكان
الختم التوقيع التاريخ الاسماء
فهو مكتمل الاركان فهو بمجرد انه يرفع على
النظام يرفع الكمبيوتر باركود النظام في
التنفيذ يقبل
بدون تدخل بشري وينفذ هو جميل هذا التطور
ولكن ما هو في صالح رواد الاعمال
وانا كل ما افتكر هذا السند افتكر كلمه
المشرف لما جاني وقال حنقلب عده قلبات
فهذه كانت هي القربه الام الرئيسيه من راس
الهرم
في هذه الاثناء حاولت ادخل وسيط
الطرف الثاني طالما كشف لنا الموضوع
يعني فكان النقاش عن انه هل صحيح تستحق
هذا المبلغ طب انت كم راتبك
الرواتب المشرف والمندوبين ما تتعدل
الخمسه الاف 4000 ريال
ولو افترضنا العمل من 2012 الى 15 او من
11 الى 15
وراتب الاربعه الاف خمسه الاف نهايه
الخدمه تكون 30 الف
والحمد لله لما كنا يعني
نحقق على النجاح في العمل التجاري كنا
نعمل زي
الجلسات اللي يكون فيها مثلا توزيع مكافات
توزيع عملات فخلينا نقول نهايه الخدمه
مغطيه يعني بالكامل وزياده
فالعجيب انه
طلبت من المحامي حلول سريعه لهذا الوضع
لانه انا نشاط الرئيسي العقارات والمحطات
البنزين هذا الانشطه
الايقافات
هي يطلق عليها ايقاف مالي
الايقافات هذه تعطلت من الاشياء
يعني التاجر يعني ما يستطيع يستغني عنه
مثلا
عندك افراغ عقاري
وانت تمثل البائع
الموثق لما يحضر للمكتب عندي
ويطلب مني البصمه
فكان شيء جديد علي انا ما كنت اتوقع انه
توصل حتى للافراغ يعني فكان موثق جميل
والموفقين دائما يتميزوا بالحكمه فما يبغى
يعني يعمل بلبله في البيعه فيبدا يقشر لي
يرسل لي واتساب هل عندك مشكله ترى ما هو
راضي ينقبل البصمه واذكر في بيعه كبيره
كانت يعني
اكثر من 11 مليون
وكنا في برج في جده اسمه برج الشاشه في
طريق الملك
وطرف الثاني رجل اعمال كبير جدا
فكان الموثق يحاول المره الاولى الثانيه
البصمه
ما هو راضي يقبل
الطرف الثاني لو شعر انه في مشكله في
الوكيل
يشعر انه البيعه فيها اشكال او شيء ممكن
الجهد حق التسويق الطويل يعني يروح في
ثواني ينسحب بالراحه فكان الموثق وهو جميل
الله يمسيه بالخير
فكان يقول لي اشوف الواتساب فيرسل لي على
الواتساب هل عندك ايقاف هل عندك عقوبات
فانا ناسي الموقف اصلا
من طبيعه دائما عند الافراغ يكون دائما
شخص معايا من الشباب
والحمد لله كان
خلال دقائق معدوده عملنا وكاله جديده
للشخص الثاني بدون ما يشعر الطرف الثاني
انه في اشكال
احنا كنا نفرق في بنك في البرج
فطلبت من
العامل احضار الضيافه عشان اكسب الوقت في
الافراغ وعمل الوكاله للشخص الثاني بدون
ما يشعر
المشتري
خصوصا المسدد التصرف العقاري مبلغ كبير
وخلاص يعني موثق موجود والبيانات باقي بس
البصمه
الشخص الثاني
وانا بعمل له الوكاله اقول له اعطيني
هويتك يعني ملامه عينه ايش فيه يا ابو
فيصل انت بتحطها باسمي مو فاهم مسكين
انه في عندي مشكله
الحمد لله تمت على خير هذه احدى العقبات
يعني ما تتخيلها
من جراء الايقافات الماليه
البنوك انت تشوف المبلغ عندك في الحساب
تروح للصرافه الاولى
تسحب ما تقدر تسحب راجع الفرع في رسائل
جميله تجيك بنتعبك معانا زر الفرع فنستغرب
انتحبك انا ازور الفرع الان اذا هي زياره
فرع اروح ازور فقال لي انت يا اخي عندك
في مشكله لا ما عندي مشكله
فيقول لي والله ظاهر عندي في السيستم انه
في مشكله طيب نراجع مين نراجع وزاره العدل
او راجع ناجز فانا اتذكر الموقف يعني في
البدايه انا اذكر يعني القصص هذه كانت
جديده
طيب سداد فاتوره يقول لي ولا شيء
كل حساباتك من البنك المركزي التجميد يصدر
بعد تقريبا اسبوع الى عشره ايام من صدور
الفاتوره
شيء جديد الفتره هذه كانت فتره يعني
مشاورات
واضح احيانا الواحد يستدرك انه دراسه
المحاماه تخصص مهم
يعني في بداياتنا في التجاره ما كنا
نستعين بمحامي الا عند الضروره يعني مثلا
عند تسجيل العقد ولكن انا اشوف مهنه
المحاماه هي مهنه يعني
يعني ضروري يكون مع رائد العماله والتاجر
محامي مستشار في الاشياء البسيطه والاشياء
الكبيره
لكن الحياه تعلمت
فكان المحامي
الله يحفظه يقول لي ترى يمكن ندخل في
سنتين
قلت له انا شهرين
في هذه المداولات واللخبطه
اشعر ان الوقت يعني طويل كيف سنتين قال لي
سنتين وانت ممنوع من السفر
وايقاف عصاباتك مجمد نعم صحيح
سعاده المحامله يقول لي سنتين انا اعتقد
في البدايه انه جزء من
تهدئه اللعب انه يا عميلي يعني لا تجيني
كل يوم بعد المغرب خليها اسبوع اسبوعين
لما يعني يجد جديد ان شاء الله اكلمك
وابو فيصل ما عنده الا ايش قهوه ودله وعسل
وبسم الله تعالى
وجار والرسول وصفه بالجر اللهم صل وسلم
فكان يقول لي كلمه
ومن اهل الشمال فكان يقول لي اصبر الله
يهديك وفي كلام ما افهم عليه الا افهم منه
يا اخي لا تجي اصبر علينا
واذا خلصنا
الخصم على الحجر وال
ان كانوا يقول لي لك انت الحريه بعدين
النظام يقفل لك العقوبه بعدين كيف ترده
للخصم فاصبر
لكن كلمه السنتين بالنسبه لي هذه كانت
شويه يعني الواحد لما يقول شخص اخر يعني
اصبر شهر شهرين مقبول سنتين عمر
حصلت مواقف حاول يعني ابرزها انا انسان
احب اصيد كل اسبوع الى اسبوعين
فهمك اي نعم
انا كل بالي لما تقول لواحد منع من السفر
هو منع من السفر بالطائره
لبس الصيد الشورت
والبندانه والكاب
ونشتري اللعف اللي هو السردين والسلماني
والسنارات والجلب والصيادين المحترفين
وعاده الرحلات الصيد من ثمانيه الى 12
ساعه
واذكر في ذي الرحله كانوا معي العائله
الفيصل
واربع بنات وولد فيصل الله يحفظك
فوصلنا عند نقطه اللي هي حرس الحدود
حرس الحدود
اليوم اتطور النظام سعر تصريح الكتروني
هو كان توصل عند نقطه كرت العائله او
الهويه تفضلوا
وبعضهم يمزح معك لا تنسونا وبعضهم يقول لك
ان شاء الله ربي يرزقكم يعني حسب الاعلان
تغير النظام لا توصل كل الالكتروني
صاحب المركب او البوت يقول لي
اعطيني هويتك
انا الى الان
الهواء جميل
واحنا فوق البحر
وصاحب المركب زميل فيطلب مني الهويه اللي
تخاله في التلخيص
اعتقد اسم المنصه ابحار
الهويه لو سمحت طبعا الجو سخب البنات
الهواء يعني جالس انقل الهويه من بعيد
وانا في قمه السعاده
لا حط صفر خمسه حط لا غلط ابو فيصل عيد
سته مرات واحنا العيد في الرقم
المره الاخيره انا بديت افتكر موضوع السند
قال لي ممكن تجيني هنا يا ابو فيصل
يبغى يخرجني من الجو
العائله الى الجو الرسمي قال لي ترى ما هو
راضي يطلع عندك التصريح التصريح
قلت له طيب احنا
ترخيص ممكن يلغى ترى دائما تجينا احراجات
والتعليمات وكبر الموضوع
طيب يعني هنا حسيت انه السفر لا ما يعني
السفر فقط في المطارات والطائره ممكن يعني
حتى نقطه بحر
فهذه من الاشياء يعني كانت يعني شو رجعنا
طبعا
وكانوا يسالوني الاطفال السبب الرجال فقلت
لهم الهواء متيار
الامواج وصرت اقول لهم عبارات يعني مطاطيه
ان شاء الله نعوضكم قريب
يعني المواقف كثير سعاده المحامي كان يقول
لي ابو فيصل
في هذه الحالات
الحل الوحيد المنازع التنفيذيه
مش المناسب التنفيذيه
هو انك انت تطعن في هذا السند
وهذا حق مشروع
فقلت له يعني
نرفع طلب ولا الكتروني قال لي كله
الكتروني الان
ومن بعد كورونا كله عن بعد الجلسات ما عدا
شك معين
يبدون الجنائي او الاشياء الكبيره
فقال لي انت يعني متاكد انك انت ما كتبت
هذا السنه قلت له يا اخي هل في شخص عاقل
يكتب على نفسه سند عده ملايين ينسى
ويبصم ما ما اقول
وين الشهود
انت اليوم لو تستاجر شقه تجيب لك شاهدين
لو يعني
فقال لي متاكد ترى فيها شغل قلت له انا
جاهز صاحب الحق دائما شجاع وواثق
فتحدت اول جلسه 17 رمضان
دائما الانسان اللي يكون على حق فالحين 24
شعبان الرساله الاولى فيعني فتره ثلاث
اسابيع يعني تقريبا
انت وكلت هذا المحامي بوكاله شرعيه مدتها
سنه
واجراءات الوكاله والعقد الى اخره المفروض
ما تحضر الجلسه تطلب تقرير
لكن
خليني اقول المبلغ الكبير او خلينا نقول
من القصه الغريبه والعجيبه فكنت احضر انا
بنفسي وكنت احضر نفسي مع
المحامي حتى اذكر كان المحامي يطلب
فتح الميكروفون وكان يقول المحامي حاضر
يعني استريح يا اصيل لا تتكلم
لكن من الحره ومن الحماس كنت انا يعني
ابغى اجاوب اي سؤال يساله
فلما شافوني يعني
ماني راضي يعني عندك تظهر في الشات الاسم
او ضيف
كاتب العدل او القاضي
الطرف الاخر يظهر باسمه انا كنت احضر
باسمي الثلاثي يعني
محضر على قولتهم جاهز طب ايش فائده
المحامي ما انت
كان يرسل لي على الواتساب
عباره اركد بارك الله فيك المحامي
بدات اول جلسه اي سؤال من القاده تلقاني
انا اللي اجاوب طيب وهذا اللي جالس يحضر
مسكين المحامي
لمن احس ان السؤال كذا فيله عده
يعني
اجوبه او في مخزن من القاضي اخلي المحامي
يتكلم
وكانت من الاشياء يعني طريفه انه بعد كل
جلسه اطلب من المحامي تقرير فكان يرسل لي
الايموجي المضحك هذا بالدموع ويقول لي
اعطت التقرير وانت حاضر قبلي في الجلسه
وتتكلم مع القاضي وتطلب تقرير وش خليت يا
ابو فيصل كنت اقول له اي جلسه ابغى تقرير
هل كان يحضر المشرف
صاحب السند الطرف الثاني ما كان يحضر يحضر
محامي
الجلسه الاولى في 17 ما قدرت تواصلت ما
بغيت تتواصل مع الطرف الثاني
2015 الى 2020 السنه ما تواصل معي ولا
تواصلت معه لا رساله ولا اسم ولا واتساب
ولا مكالمه
ودائما يعني تصفى المشاكل
والخلافات في المكاتب
اذا تعذرت المحاكم ولكن ما هو بسند تنفيذي
ومزور بس انت يعني يوم طلع هذا عرفت انه
شخصيات واصل ما توصلنا الا اللي يتخذ طريق
المحاكم تكمل معاه بالمحكم فانت تتجلسه
الاولى الجلسه الاولى حكموا القاضي
برفع العقوبات
فورا
ورد السند ليش
كان يسال الطرف محامي الطرف الاخر هذه
الملايين مقابل ماذا فكان الرد مقابل اتعب
فكان المحامي يقول الراتب 4000
هل الاتعاب
اكثر من 4 مليون
فالكاضي يرد الدعوه لهذا السبب
القضاء
عادل ونزيه بعد حكم القاضي يحاول
الاستئناف ثلاثه قضاه
ما هو منهم القاضي الاول
ينظر في القضيه وفي حكم القاضي
واما يؤيد واما يعاد للدراسه
الاستئناف
اخروا الحكم الى شهر شوال
حكم الاستئناف
بانه
السند يجب ان يدرس من الادله الجنائيه
للتاكد من توقيع الطرف الاول من عدم
ومن هنا بدا التاخر الموضوع والحسب
راي القضاه الثلاثه الاستئناف انه
القاضي حكم برد السند بدون ما يدرس
وضع السند
والادله الجنائيه يعني يوجد فيها مهندسين
المقاطع الصوتيه والتواقيع فيجب ان يحال
السند
الطرف الثاني
يجب ان يسلم اصل السند الى المحكمه
والمحكمه تحيل اصل السند للادله الجنائيه
الطرف الاخر لم يسلم السند
فانت تستمر
حتى يسلم الطرف الاخر السند
وصل التاخر الى سته اشهر
الطريق الوحيده للضغط زياره القاضي وارسال
ايميل للدائره
بانه لم يصل السند الادله الجنائيه
سته اشهر وشهرين الاولى ثمانيه اشهر
خلال هذه ثمانيه اشهر
العقوبات مستمره
الايقافات مستمره الحسابات البنكيه مجمده
عندك التزامات عندك رواتب عندك عائله
كنا نسمع لا تضع البيض في سله واحده
فحقيقه هذه الحكمه او المثل حقيقي
الانسان لما يكون مساهم ومشارك في عده
شركات حتى لو مؤسسات صغيره
صديق عند الضيق
يعني كانت
يعني تعرف معدن الرجال في هذا الفتره
يحق لك النظام انك
اذا كان حساب شركه
ما يتوقف الا المدير انت ما انت مدير فكان
حساب بعض الحسابات
نشطه
تحول اليها الارباح والمبالغ او نسبه
الشراكه فيها كان الانسان يعني يدبر نفسه
بهذه الامور
عندك بعض المشتغل
نقديه يعني كان شغل نقدي وكان في نفس
الوقت
يعني مثلا بالنسبه للقطاع العقاري عندي
عميل دفع
يبغى يدفع قيمه عقد للمنشاه عندك شبكه
ايجار
يعني هذه الاله من الاسرار شبكه ايجار
فيها مرونه صاحب المكتب او الشركه
العقاريه الحساب البنكي اللي تبغى العميل
يحول عليه
ضع الايبان والحساب مالهم دخل انه والله
هل هو تابع للشركه فكان هذا جدا
مخرج لاصحاب
الاعمال اللي عندهم اشكال يعني هذه كانت
احدى الحلول
وعقود شبكه ايجار هذه الايام اعتقد اي عقد
الان ورقي مرفوض
ومفتشين وزاره الاسكان يعني كانوا يعملوا
جولات على الشركات والمكاتب
اذا وجدوا عقد ورقي غرامه كبيره وتوصل الى
اغلاق المكتب
بعد ثمانيه الى تسعه اشهر
كان في هذه الفتره الفريق اللي يعمل في
الموضوع كان منظم
محامي المستشارين ومحامي موقع مع عقد مكتب
وثلاثه معقبين او كلاء شرعيين كان لكل شخص
مهمه
فالفريق كان ما يجتمع في مكان واحد عشان
كنت احرص على عدم اخذ المعلومات يعني
معلومه تجري للوكيل الاول انا ما ابغى تجي
للوكيل الثاني فكنت حريص انه كل واحد
اقابله في اجتماع خاص على حدا
فالمعجب ما يعرف المحامي والمحامي ما يعرف
المعجب حتى لا يكون في تواصل او شيء ما
اقدر اعمل عليه كنترول
فكان المعجب الاول المتخصص في الادله
الجنائيه كان تقريبا شبه اسبوعي يزور
الادله ويقول لهم هل وصل السند
فاحدث زيارات اتصل عليه وقال لي وصل السند
الشخص المذنب اذا وصل السند وفيها ادله
جنائيه وتحقيق يشعر
بتعب بحثا اثار عمليه سفر الى اخره اي
اشكال
وكيل محامي انا كنت حريص جدا على
اذكر مكالمه
المامور في الادله الجنائيه او الاستقبال
الساعه واحده ظهرا
سلام عليكم فلان نعم بكره الساعه ثمانيه
صباحا
تكون جاهز معنا
فانا كان سؤالي طب ايش اجيب معي قال لي
ولا شيء الهويه والله
شيء جديد
ادله جنائيه وزاره الداخليه شرطي يعني
حاجه جديده فكنت اقول المحامي يعني هل
عندهم
خبره انهم يعرفوا هذا التوقيع توقيعي في
ناس عندهم
يعني مهاره في الخط ممكن يقلد فكان
المحامي يعني يضحك ويقول لي
المهندس في الادله الجنائيه لو انك موقع
برجلك يعرف ان هذا توقيع بالقدم وليس
باليد فكان هذا شيء مطمئن
الموعد كان ثمانيه صباحا ان الساعه
السابعه صباحا موجود
ومعايا تقريبا اربع اشخاص كلهم وكلاء
شرعيين
الضابط عنده اول واحد شاهد بالحليب الصباح
يلاقي اربعه يعني هو عنده الجدول واحد
اللي بيقابل هذول الاربعه مين
فكان يكلم واحد من الشباب يقول له عفوا
انتوا فزعه ولا ماني فاهم واحنا هنقابل
واحد ونشوف التوقيع فكان رده هذا والله
محامي وهذا وكيل وهذا معقب قال يا جماعه
ما يحتاج وتراه بيطول عندنا انت عندكم
اعمال روحوا اصر الفريق على البقاء
الساعه التاسعه بدا
التوقيع والتحقيق الاول شيء جديد المحقق
يعني في المكتب وانا امامه واوراق واقلام
انا توقعت في التحقيق انه يحضر الطرف
الاخر ويكون فيه زي المواجهه وكنت اتمنى
هذا الشيء لانه على طول عندي عده اسئله
افحمه فيها تفاجات انه قال لا انت فقط
انه انت صاحب السند قلت له يا عزيزي انا
ما صرت اقول له هل هناك شخص عاقل يوقع سند
فايد نفسه كان يقول عموما انت الان في هذه
المشكله
عندي عده اسئله وكذا
واكتب اسمك هويتك
بعد الجوال شويه عشان تاخذ راحتك
فاذكر في هذاك اليوم بدانا يعني انا وصلت
سبعه خرجت صلاه الظهر او بعد صلاه الظهر
لدرجه انه يعني كنت اقول له ممكن دقيقه
بريك يعني احرك يدي من كثره
وقع صفحه كامله وكان الصفحه وقع توقيع
صغير بنوك
فقلت له معلش ممكن اسالك سؤال يا
سعاده الضابط
قال لي تفضل قلت له انا عندي عده تواقيع
البنك الازرق توقيع بنك الاخضر توقيع
البنك الموف توقيع تبغاني اوقع لك اي
توقيع ما اعرف اجاوبني
كل اللي تشوفوه يعني هو تفاجئ من جوابي
وانا صادق يعني انا عندي عده
قال لي وقع التوقيع اللي انت دائما توقع
طبعا انا سند يعني في الذاكره
وشايف التوقيع في المخيله عندي والذاكره
فكنت احاول اتجنب اجيب توقيع يعني قريب من
هذا التوقيع فكنت اجيب توقيع مخالف تماما
فياخذ الاوراق ويمزقها انا ما ابغى هذا
التوقيع يعني واضح انه الملف درسه دراسه
كامله قبل
ابغاك توقع التوقيع هذاك
انا بدا يعني يزيد عندي
الادرينالين اذا صح الاسم
ويعني طلبت
يعني بدات يعني اشعر انه الوضع انت تبغاني
اوقع نفس التوقيع وتكتب مطابق مطبق علي
فكنت افتح قصص خارج الموضوع
اذكر
كان هو يعني يعشق القهوه
فكان يقول لي هل تقدر تجيب لي بما انه انت
نشاطك في محطه الوقود وكاله هذا البراند
الى القريه اللي نسكن فيها خارج جده
القريه
فانا على علاقه قويه بصاحب البراند القهوه
اللي يطلبها
فكان هذا المخرج يعني مخرج كان بالنسبه لي
مريح
اني يعني اهدي الموضوع واحاول يعني افهم
طلبه اني اجيب نفس التوقيع اللي في السند
وبعدين انت كلجنه تفحص وتقول مطابق
المحامي دائما يعني يعطيك ارشادات ويعطيك
افكار ولكن في اشياء
انت تصارعها بنفسك وهذه من الاشياء يعني
العجيبه في هذا الموقف ما استطيع اتصل على
المحامي اقول له الضابط امامي يطلب توقيع
مطابق للسند
توكلت فوق وقعت نفس التوقيع
والعجيب انه يقول لك وقع كبير صفحه كامله
بعدين يجيب لي صفحه مربعه بعدين اصغر
يخليني اوجه الى الف توقيع
اربع اقلام جنبي يعني مو انه الحبر يخلص
لا انا اتعب اقوم احرك اغير اريح اطلب
بريك
صلاه الظهر اذن
وصل المحقق الثاني والثالث سعره ثلاثه
محققين امامي
فكل ما جاء واحد اقول له ترى والله مو انا
لموقع سنه يا اخي والله صادق والطرف
الثاني يقول انا نفس الكلام وصادق ولكن
احنا لازم ندرس
يعني كنت امزح مع الضابط واقول له يا ابوي
لا تنكب الله يرحم امك فكان يقول لي هذا
عملي
وقلت له انا مقدر هذا العمل ولكن الموضوع
عده ملايين يعني ما هو الموضوع فاتوره
بعشره الاف الواحد يدفعه يعتبرها خساره في
اي تجاره
انتهى التوقيع
نسيت الهويه في المكتب
الضابط
قال لي نسيت هويتك قلت له والله من كثره
التوقي انا نسيت انا وين
اخذت الهويه وقلت له طب ايش ايش الاليه
قال لي راجع للقضاء
احنا بندرس
عندنا وقت
للجنه
تسمى اللجنه الهندسيه للتواقع
طبعا الفريق المتخصص اللي يتابع عندي بين
الادله الجنائيه وبين المحكمه ثاني يوم
قدوم مداوم يبغى يلحق هالدرس جلس السنه
تقريبا ثلاثه اشهر
[موسيقى]
حصلت يعني
شدات في المواضيع هذه يعني اذكر منها مثلا
كانت ضابط يعني يطلب من المعقب او الوكيل
لعدم الحضور بشكل مستمر والمتابع فقط مع
المحكمه وعدم الحضور الادله وكنا مقدرين
هذا الوضع
بعد ثلاثه اشهر
وصل للمحكمه
وما يعني الشخص الاطراف ما توصل لهم رساله
نصيه انه ترى وصل المستند اذا انت ما
تراجع ما تعرف ما تعرف
فوصل يعني وصلني الخبر انه وصل الملف
الملف يعني يطلق عليه مغلق بالشمع الاحمر
فكنت اطلب طلب واحد من كاتب الضبط او
المشرفين عند القاضي
يا اخي انا الاصيل
وابغى اشوف نتيجه
فحص الادله الجنائيه يا اخي
حق انت تقول هذا توقيعي وانا اقول لكم هذا
ما هو توقيعي ابغى اشوف النتيجه
فكان يعني ردوا حازم
يجب تحديد جلسه قضائيه
يعني الانسان واثق من نفسه انه ما كتب
وواثق من على قولتهم يعني طريقته انه ما
يوقع سندات الامر ولا شيكات من غير رصيد
والاخرين لكن سبحان الله في النفس شيء
شيء جديد فكنت اخشى ان التوقيع
اتصلت على سعاده المحامي قلت له القهوه
جاهزه انا جايك
فكان يعني الرجل هذا عجيب وكان يضحك ويقول
لي عسى ما جبت العيد
قلت له المحقق يطلب مني توقيع مطابق للسند
وهنا ظبطت له توقيع مطابق للسند بناء على
طلبه
فسهر يقول لي يجيب الله خير
الله يستر عليك وكان يضحك
في هذه الاثناء
النظام يطلب من الطرفين تحديد جلسه
الطرف الاخر
ما يعرف النتيجه
والطرف الاول ما يعرف النتيجه لا هو طلب
تحديد جلسه ولا انا طلبت تحديد جلسه
فجلس الموضوع معلق عده اشهر
طلب المحامي مني موعد مقابله وقال لي يا
اخي اسمه
العقوبه صادره عليك الان كملنا سنه وعده
اشهر
اكثر من كذا ما في
توكل على الله وحد الجلسه قلت له ابد
واشتغل ايش كان مخليك تتردد
قلت انا مرتاح
قال لي انت متعطل قلت له ابد اذا هي فيها
مطابقه
انا اقول لك انا مرتاح وخليها كذا هو اللي
يطلب تحديد الجلسه
وبالفعل
الطرف الاخر
حمل تاشيره خروج وعوده
12 شهر
ووكل المحامي وبهذه الاليه اتبعها المشرف
حمى نفسه من ايش عقوبه التزوير او السجن
بحيث انه لو صدر الحكم هو خارج البلد
والمحامي موجود صدر الحكم لصالحه رجع رجع
ويتقاسموا المبالغ او شوفوا الاليه اللي
اتفقوا فيها معاه في العقد بينهم
بالفعل تحدث الجلسه وانا الان امام الامر
الواقع وهو بر السعوديه هو بر السعوديه
واللي يرفع الجلسه محامي سعودي
والعجيب والغريب انه جميع المحامين
في نفس الحاره وجيراني لكن ما اعرفهم يعني
ما تجمع العلاقه ولكن العجيب انه كلهم في
حاره واحده وجنبها
الطرف الاخر خارج المملكه الضغط عليها اخف
الطرف الاول داخل المملكه
والسيف عليه
تحدث الجلسه
كالعاده الطرف الاول حاضر والمحامي حاضر
ومحضر نفسي انا بالاسم الثلاثي
هذه الاثناء تغير القاضي
القاضي الاول انتقل الى مدينه اخرى وحظر
قاضي جديد ما يعرف عن الحكم الاول اللي
ردت فيه الدعوه
فكانه ينظر للقضيه من جديد
وهذا شيء ما هو في صالح الطرف الاول
تحدث الجلسات
وتعددت
القضايا وبين كل جلسه وجلسه ثلاثه اشهر
في احدى الجلسات طلبت من القاضي مواجهه
الطرف الثاني
وبعض القضايا القاضي يعني ما يستطيع فراسه
يحلها الا بالمواجهه
فامر القاضي
من محامي الشخص الاخر بتحضير الطرف الثاني
في الجلسه
والنظام اذا جلسه جلستين لم يحضر وعصر امر
القاضي يحكم ضده او يحكم بما يراه
فالجلسه الثانيه خلاها بعد اسبوع يعني
خلينا نقول القاضي يبغى يحسم الموضوع
وجميع الاطراف تبي تحسن
حضر الطرف الثاني في الجلسه عن بعد فهو
كله عن بعد فهو ما رجع نعم كله عن بعد
جلسات القضاء الحساسه
الوضع كالتالي
حامل الجوال اول
لابتوب القضيه
جوال ثالث او ثاني استشاره مع المحامين
محامي يعني جلسه
عمليات او مكتب عمليات الكلمه محسوبه ممكن
كلمه تقولها يصدر عليك الحكم
وممكن كل كلمه تنساها يصدر الحكم في يعني
ما هو في صالحك ضدك كان الوضع يعني
حساس جدا
واغلب الجلسات تكون الساعه 11 الصباح قبل
صلاه الظهر انسان يكون في قمه النشاط
والحيويه
حضر الخصم
اول مواجهه بعد تقريبا الان صار 2022 يعني
سبع سنوات
ما سمعت صوتي ولا سمعت
كان القاضي طبعا دائما القاضي في
اداره في جلسات القضاء عن بعد تكون حازمه
جدا لعدم التضارب الاصوات فكان اذا سمح لك
بالكلام تتكلم ما سمح لك بالكلام ممكن
يخرجك من الجلسه
فكان المحامي
يتكلم
وهو الان القاضي ما يبغى المحامي يتكلم
يبغى الطرفين يتكلموا وتحصل مواجهه وبعدها
يقرر هل هذا السينات صحيح او غير صحيح
فانا وجهت سؤالي بدون اي ترتيب مع
المحامين
القاضي ايش طلع نتيجه الدليل الادله
الجنائيه بالنسبه للتوقيع غير مطابق اه
غير
[موسيقى]
وليش ما حكم بدون خلاص يعني
هل عندك بين اخرى اه فما كانت فرصه
فرصه وفرصتين او ثلاثه
وهذه يعني ما هي في صالح الطرف الاول في
صالح الطرف الثاني ولكن يعني هذا قضاء
ممتاز ونقبل فيه فكنت مجهز سؤالك سؤالك
التالي
اين استلمت السند
والوقت والشهود
السؤال كان غير مرتب لا مع المحامي ولا
الطرف الاخر يعني متوقع هذا السؤال
فكان في تردد في الجواب وتاتاه والقاضي
دائما يتميز بالفراسه ويعني
الجواب يكون الان بين قوسين فكان جواب
واستلمته في منزلك
في اليوم المدون في السند يعني حتى هو ما
هو ذاكر هذا التاريخ طب انت مبلغ زي هذا
المفروض يكون هذا يعني بالنسبه لك تاسيس
تاسيس حياتك الجديده مبلغ ملايين يعني
معقوله ما تذكر تقول لي ارجع للسند
حتى السؤال مره ثانيه اين استلمت السند
ومنع الحضور ومتى
فالاجابه كانت غير صحيحه ذكر حي انا ما
املك فيه عقار
فطلبت من القاضي المداخله اذن قلت له انا
ما املك عقار في هذا المكان
وما قابلته في هذا المكان
فكان يعني يوجه سؤال القاضي للخصم
وش تقول في كلام الاخ عبد الله ابو فيصل
فكان يقول
انا ما افتكر الكلام قديم كل شلون الكلام
قديم فكان القاضي كانه محامي
سالته سؤال واعتبره هو الضرب القاضيه على
قوله الرياضة الملاكمه
السند استلمته من شخصيا
في الطرف الثاني قال نعم
وانا كنت في هذا اليوم خارج المملكه اه
انت كنت
هذه يعني سبحان الله يعني
من صبر ظفر يعني سنتين تقريبا وكان يعني
توفيق من الله ما هو ذكاء وما كان في
ترتيب يعني على عده جلسات مع المحامي ما
كنا مرتبين لهذا الاخراج اللي يطلع بهذه
الطريقه
في القاضي يوجه سؤاله وايش تقول بهذه
العباره العاميه وش تقول في ان الرجال
يقول لك كان خارج المملكه شلون استلمت منه
يعني بتجننون انت ولا ايش
الطرف الثاني يعني تردد في الجواب
ويبدو لي انه غير
يعني ما هو جالس مع المحامي فما هم عارفين
يتواصلوا بالواتساب او شيء فما اعرف يجاوب
فالقاضي طلب ارفاق اثبات انك انت خارج
المملكه في النظام
انا قدني من قبلها بعده ايام بي دي اف
ومرتبه وجاهز خمس نجوم اخراج على كيف كيفك
في عندنا في القضاء دردشه
يا عبد الله بصيغه عنيفه من القاضي ارفق
الاثبات في الدردشه
انا من الحماس ارفقته مرتين
واضح اني خارج المملكه
القاضي سبحان الله يعني
لعله في ذلك خير
ما طلب
انه حيحكم الان فورا طلب الرد للدراسه او
مهرئ للدراسه
ختم الجلسه
المحامين انا معي فريق المحاماه عددهم
خمسه
الجميع ارسل لي واتساب على البركه يا ابو
فيصل
حسمت
اتصلت عليهم وقلت لهم
حسمت بفضل الله ثم بسؤال
اين استلمت السند وانا كنت خارج المملكه
يعني ما هو ذكاء منك يا محامي او يعني
زي الدقه بيني وبين المحامين يعني
الجلسه الثانيه القاضي بيحسم فكانت بعدها
بعشره ايام عكس اول شهرين ثلاثه الان عشره
ايام
القاضي الان يضع الاسباب فيسمى تسبيب
القاضي
الجلسه الثانيه
كانت الساعه 11:30 كنت في عمل في مكه
المكرمه
وحرست انه يعني هي جات مصادفه اني في مكه
فحرست انه العمل كان الساعه عشره تقريبا
في العقارات والصكوك كذا
والافراغ ما تقدر تفرغ لكن في اشياء
كوكالات ممكن تسويها مثلا تحديث الصكوك
تعديل الصكوك متاح لك ما عندك يعني
ايقافات فيه فقط الافراغ او اي شيء فيله
مالي يعني الاشياء الماليه
فهذاك اليوم حرصت اني اصلي صلاه الفجر في
الحرم المكي وانا من شرح
ان الحكم هيكون صالح في صالح لكن ما عندي
على قولتهم يعني شيء مطمع لكن توكلت على
الله واذكر الشخص المرافق يعني
رسالتي له الساعه اثنين الفجر او ثلاثه
خليك جاهز عندي في المنزل على مكه عندنا
شغل فارسل لي ايش الدائره الحكوميه الا
فتحه هذا الوقت فقلت له في شيء في بالي
وصلنا كان الشيخ ياسر الدوسري يعني وصلنا
الركعه الاولى صوت جميل صلينا في الساحه
الجو وهذا كان بارد
سبحان الله يعني الصدر من شرح ان الحكم ان
شاء الله في صالحه والسنتين هذي تطوى ان
شاء الله للابد
لكن ما في
بعد ما صلينا يعني عندنا موعد العمل
الساعه العاشره
ذهبت عند واحد من الشباب يعني صديق وفي
نفس الوقت عندنا مهمه العمل ننجزها
سبحان الله
جميع الجلسات
ما اذكر عددها من كثره جميع الجلسات اول
واحد يحضر هو الطرف الاول ابو فيصل عبد
الله
الجلسه الاخيره وهي اهم جلسه النطق بالحكم
ابو فيصل حط الجوال بعيد ومشغول مع زميله
وفي انهاء العمل بدات الجلسه وحكم القاضي
قلت ما حضرت وانا ما حضرت ليه
مشغول معه الزميل
الجوال
يرن والواتسابات
يعني صوتها ورا بعض الزميل يقول لي في شيء
مهم في جوالك روح شوف
قلت له الجلسه
جلسه ايش الحين هذا مو عارف ايش الموضوع
قلت له في جلسه قديمه من سنتين واحد
ركبنا الله كذا بالعاميه انا بتكلم معها
قال لي يلا خير ترى شكله ان شاء الله في
صالحك الاتصالات كثيره
اول اتصال اشوف المكالمات الفائته المحامي
فلان سعاده المحامي فلان مكتب مدري ايش
محاماه كنت
رديت على اكبرهم
على البركه حكم لك
انا اقول له يا رجال بدات الجلسه قال لي
اقول لك حكم لك عده ثواني
السند باطل وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين رفعت الجلسه
يعني اقل من ثواني
العقوبات ترفع خلال 24 ساعه
ومكتوب في الصك بالقوه الجبريه ولو استدعت
الشرطه لازاله الحكومه
سبحان الله يعني الموقف عجيب
تحضر الجلسات الثانويه او البدايه اللي
كان فيها مثلا سؤال وجواب والحكم يعني انا
اقول هذا العلو ثبات
وطمانينه وراحه الشخص
ومن الفرحه فقلت للزميل وين القبله
الحين موضوعنا احنا موضوع ثاني مهم وانا
موضوعي اهم
ترك الرجال الموضوع وقال لي يا اخي شو
القصه
فشرحت الموضوع قال اسمع هذه ما يبغى لها
جلسه مكاتب هذه يبغى لها جلسه بره عندي
مخيم في منطقه تبعد ساعه ونجيب الشباب
والعقارين ونتفاهم
والرجال ما قصر وذبح وصلنا وهذي الطريق
جالس احكي القصه
والحمد لله على كل حال طبعا
اول العقوبات كانت تاخذ وقت
الان بمجرد صدور الحكم
يصدر صك حكم ويصدر بعدها محضر انها
خلال 24 ساعه تفتح الحسابات البنكيه وترفع
العقوبات فوق
هذه كانت القصه يعني وهو
طبعا الان انت النظام يعني
يكفل لك اكثر من حق الاول اتعاب القضاء
اتعب الطرف الثاني
سند اذا ابطل بالتزوير قد يسجن الشخص
الاخر ويبعد من البلد لكن السند هنا ابطل
ما هو للتزوير لعدم ثبوته
ولعدم استحقاقه
وابطل فسقطت
عقوبه السجن والتزوير
وفي الحقيقه يعني
انا اتمنى انه كان
المشرف او الموظف
يعني تنتهي الخلافات في المكاتب
يعني
ما وجدت حل في المكتب تشكيل لجنه من
الطرفين
يعني الواحد ما يعني يكون حريص على
المحاكم الا اذا يعني عمل اكثر من محاوله
للصلح ليه كان يعتقد هو انها حقه هو الى
اخر لحظه والى اخر لحظه وحضور وحتى في
جلسه النطق والحكم كان موجود يعني عنده
امل انه يفوز بهذا المبلغ بس هل كان هو
يعتقد ان حق ولا هو زورها وفعلا بس كان
يبغى ياخذ فلوس والله اعلم انه حسب ما
وصلني من الوسيط انه في محامي اثر عليه
وقال طالما الختم المطبوعات موجوده فانت
بترفع عليه اسبوع رجل اعمال ما يتحمل منع
سفر ما يتحمل فلوس الشركات والراتب بيدفع
لك ورساله جميله تجيله في ذاك الليل وهو
مروق ثاني يوم قدوم حول لك المبلغ كان هذا
اعتقادهم لكن لحمه نمر ما هو سهل ان
الواحد ياخذ هذا المبلغ وخصوصا انه بغير
حق
لو كان بحق الانسان يعني حريص دائما
الحلال ابن حرام خصوصا في التجاره
فالموضوع السند وطريقه الاخراج كانت يعني
جدا غريبه والله غريب وانا اذا يعني في
نصيحه اوجهها يعني رواد الامان او التجار
او اللبادئ في البزنس الختم المطبوعات
السندات القبض والصرف يعني هذه مثل الهويه
والله انا مسافر واخاف اتعطل وعندي فاتوره
لازم يطبعها المدير المالي حبيبي سافر
اسبوع اسبوعين وارجع غيرك جلس متعطل سنتين
مو اسبوعين فانا هذه النصيحه انه الختم
والمطبوع هي مثل الهويه تكون في خزنه خاصه
والمفتاح يكون معاك او مثلا ختم الكتروني
مع التطور اللي احنا فيه يكون فيه يعني
اليه وترتيب معين والله يعني كانت سنتين
صعبه جدا
كانت يعني سنتين صعبه وتجربه جديده على
الجميع
يعني حتى في اشياء يعني طريفه بعض الزملاء
تجارته ما تتعدى خمسين الف
يقول لي من يوم ما سمعت قصتك الختم تحت
المخده عندي
يعني يقول لي صار عندنا زي التوعيه يعني
بس الواحد ما كان ودي يكون هو التجربه لكن
سبحان الله يعني في ناس يستفيد
احنا كلنا يعني احدى التجارب والحياه يعني
تجربه وكانت قلبه جميله
والله المستعان سافرت بعدها
العقوبات رفعت تقريبا قبل 20 يوم اه والله
فهذه اول سفره الى الرياض
لكن الحساب البنكي بعد 24 ساعه
تنشطت
وكنت اسال الموظفين في البنوك اقول لهم
يعني
ايش الرساله جاتكم او ايش الكود عشان
الواحد يتعلم فقال لي الكود اللي يجينا
كود ايقاف وكود رفع من البنك المركزي
قلت له المدير الفرع ما عنده سلطه انه
يرفع الايقاف
مثلا لسداد فاتوره كهرباء معينه قال لي
ابدا
تجميد من البنك المركزي
فهذه يعني
انه خلال 24 ساعه من صدور الصك الى تنشيط
الحساب انا اعتبره يعني انجاز انه هو تحدي
والله دائما الخدمات الالكترونيه قد ما هي
انها تساعد كثير في تسهيل الاجراءات
في معظم الحالات لانه في نفس الوقت تخلي
اني اقدر اوقف الخدمات فقط سر
تصير الحياه يعني ممكن انت رقم مجرد رقم
انت مجرد رقم في الحاسب الالي اذا توقف
الرقم
اتوقف يعني كل شيء هو يعني فعلا
حسب ما سمعت من المحامين انه الايقافات
السابقه القديمه قبل كورونا
كان يوصل انه حتى السياره ما تقدر تجدد
الاستماره
حتى
اذا ربي رزقك بطفل ما تقدر تضيفه فكره
العائله يعني التجار القدماء يعني
القديمين اخذوا عقوبات
يعني مضاعفه لقيت ولدي كذا بدون يعني تخيل
يوصل الولد اذا القضيه استمرت سنتين ثلاثه
هو غير موجود
والسياره منتهيه الاستماره المرور يعني
الحياه كانت صعبه لكن هذا النظام الان حسب
ما فهمت اسمه عقوبات ماليه على التجار حتى
تنتهي القضيه بمجرد انتهاء خلال 24 ساعه
ترفع
ممتاز نعم
سؤال مهم الحين تقريبا انا الكل نشاط اطلع
له ختمين او ثلاث
الان عندي شنطه
ماركه كذا معينه قيمتها 4000 ريال
حطها في البيت
في دولاب خاص ما حد يفتحه الا ام فيصل
موجود في جميع الاختام حتى المنشات اللي
شطفت
موجوده واحد لعدم
لا سمح الله اختفاء ختم في المكاتب او
محاوله اتلاف فاشله وشخص ممكن يتلقف الختم
فمحتفظ بجميع الاختام يعني انشطه بعضها من
1400 يعني اكثر من عشرين سنه 18 سنه الختم
موجود
الحمد لله على كل حال الحمد لله على كل
حال الله يعطيك العافيه خلصنا خلصنا شكرا
لكم شكرا لايمن الحمادي وتركي القحطاني في
اعداد الحلقه جميل عبد الاحد في التحرير
وهاب موسى في التصوير ونور السبيعي في
اداره محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي عبد المجيد
العطاس في التلوين وضياء الدين المدني في
الهندسه الصوتيه واداره التحرير اسيل عبد
الله هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه 8 للنشر
والتوزيع ننشر كل الانتاج بحب بمدينه
الرياض الاسبوع المقبل القادم
[موسيقى]